well let's uh let's let's let's let's
let's deviate hard 180 not really hard
what I was gonna say this isn't too far
it's pretty much the same kind of crazy
the story yeah
check the story out well so so yeah we
just were where we were talking about
Chazz being insane and now we can go to
how the media props all this stuff up so
here it let's so this is the original
this is what started it all right here
so this is this is a tweet from NPR says
right-wing extremists are turning cars
into weapons with reports of 50 vehicle
ramming incidents since protests erupted
nationwide in late May now I'm just
gonna say I've seen multiple videos of
protesters I say this in quotes because
it's not proud it's probably not the
protesters
it's the rioters it's the people that
are taking advantage of a situation
they're pulling truckers out of their
truck beating them up in this video the
90s yeah exactly well I mean it's but
it's happening again is right yeah right
so it's like we're seeing this now when
you're in a car and and people come up
to you and start banging on your car
what do you what do you think is going
on in that person's head these people
are trying to kill me yeah I need to get
out of here it's fight or flight done
period so I don't I mean I've seen this
video I don't know how many people have
actually seen the video but it's crazy
you're absolutely wrong Adam it's
obvious people in these cars me more
time once they're surrounded by the
protestors all of a sudden the white
supremacy in their hearts debate super
if their hair turns gold and stand
straight up an energy or appears around
them and then they they thrust their arm
for and slam the gas yelling things in
German trying to hit as many people as
possible that's what the protesters
think happens right all right the inner
walls apprentices the way they are
framed this right wing extremely like
well first up how do you know is a right
wing extremists I don't know who that in
that car was do they know who was in
that car they do this particular is it
you're actually a right-wing extremist
no it's not that you want you know the
controversy with this picture is what
here pull the picture back up it is a
it's that these people surrounded her
car and were attacking the woman yeah
out of nowhere pulling on her hair and
beating her and so then she swerved and
slammed the gas
this guy jumped in front of the car and
got knocked in the air shoes flew off
yeah and they charged the protesters not
the woman in the car oh they beat her
yeah I saw it David they were trying to
pull her out of the car Oh yep like what
III I had someone in my family was
parked or not parked waiting at a red
light and some a man walked up and tried
to open the door on the on the passenger
side just tried to open the door and it
wasn't open and that my family member
freaked out and was like I I just I just
took off this was years ago and she
called the police I guess it was a
female doesn't matter but she called the
police and police said you did exactly
what I would have said for you to do
leave leave as soon as you can you're
you're you were right to have your cars
alive I mean they lock the cars lock
when you start driving nowadays new cars
but you know it was locked so no one was
able to get in but she took off and the
cop was like good that's exactly should
have done leave the situation I know it
was a red light but you yep you're fine
I was like okay so now I'm seeing this
it's like what do they expect someone
well okay you're gonna sit here and beat
me now I'll wait here let me roll down
your window yeah so they do my era they
deleted this tweet that's like the big
controversy they deleted it because the
photo actually showed a victim being
attacked by a mob and then they were
like oops they do bring up a lot of
stories where there have been contacts
yeah I like by right-wing extremists I
guess but I don't trust their definition
of what a right-wing extremist is right
apparently if you post things in support
of George Floyd and you talk about how
your plan is to kill cops and then you
do it your right wing so so this is what
I said last week you go so far left of
the screen as soon as that happens you
enter in onto the other side
Eggman they're the same they're the same
well it no it's because to the media
anything bad is right-wing yeah so even
though anti file rights kill cops all
over the place
threatens liberals as soon as one of
them goes and does it
the right wing no oh left alt left so I
was once
waiting to pick up a friend and I'm
sitting in my car was the old Honda and
then so my doors are unlocked my friend
supposed to coming in the car yeah all
of a sudden somebody walks up opens the
car and sits in the backseat and I'm
like dude what are you doing in my car
and he goes oh it's uh uber and I was
like no it isn't and he was like oh I'm
sorry and he gets out of my car and I
was like apparently it's happened it
happens a lot now imagine if they had
ill intent I know yep Drive yep yep
well I there's suddenly a situation
anybody wants to come in my car and
point a gun at me I'll be like boom and
I'll be like I'm taking you with me
buddy take you got a gun in my head
where my I don't know what you're gonna
do with it yeah screw it up I got my
seatbelt on I'm going 90 yeah anyway
there's nothing you need to stop me bro
because if you put up if you if you use
that bullet you're going down with the
best thing you can do is just jump out
yeah be stupid that's why I never
understood about like people getting
held up in cars and stuff but I'll tell
you what man there was a story in
Chicago where a firefighter pulled up to
a red light and a guy walked up to his
car and pointed a gun in the windshield
like around in the in the window and so
he slammed the gas and right when he did
the guy went pop pop and killed him so
you this is a story I heard when I was
growing up
and there's the it was I was told my my
my dad if somebody walks up to your car
and they got the gun trained on you just
get out of the getting what they want
like they might still shoot you but it's
is it worth your life
right now you lose the car we'll figure
something out I mean you see that video
of the dude washing his car in New York
and then the dude walks up and just
points the gun at his neck it's like
what's going on in the world that seems
like it like it was a targeted hit
but the reason there was another context
of it there wasn't I bring up that story
with Chicago is like where did this take
place right where this these people
surrounded this car where a bunch people
surround you and are banging on things
if you're in Chicago and someone just
walk up to your car no matter what part
of Chicago you're in you slam the gas
yeah you get out of there yep definitely
yep and so this was in in the Chicago
area that that I was the situation I
just told told earlier yeah that's why I
was saying the other day in Chicago
which is supposed to do is you're
supposed to leave a full car length and
of you yeah so that if somebody tries to
box you in or tries to carjack you slam
your gas before they get to your window
yeah exactly use take off get out of
there yeah I remember there's a there's
a trick they do where someone will be
driving up next to you and then they'll
slam the gas pull in front of you then
slam the brakes just like so you'll
rear-end them yeah yeah
then you think like it's a scam but they
just robbed you these come out with guns
they'll rob you you can't go anywhere we
need to throw it in reverse and try to
get out they got you man so someone will
be behind you they'll pull in front send
their brakes on and box you in and then
your stuff is there stuff that's how
that's how they roll you know listen you
hear stories like that about someone
walk up to your window and shooting you
what do you think these people are gonna
do when you when you when you surround
their car screaming and bang on stuff
not only hearing stories we're in the
age of social media people are seeing it
themselves they're visually seeing
people getting pulled out of their cars
be up because of the color of their skin
now I'm not talking to like white anyone
it feels like is could be a target for
this bro anybody so let me one-up you oh
please you please come on one-up me ten
yeah I'm on the show for this no I'm not
saying I'm personally I'm saying I'm
chatting to people in their car were
shot and killed in New York City I saw
this so I walked up there car went pop
pop and then their car was just stopped
and they were there just dead
this graphic video so so yeah man so why
would somebody think I'm just gonna
stand here while people are smashing my
windows pulling my hair beating me right
trying to pop my door yeah you saw the
video from the Chazz where the guy I
think was Jesse he's driving in his car
what's that Chaz where the guy gets out
of his car and then shoots shoots of the
window that was in Seattle yeah yeah so
a guy is driving down this road and a
bunch of protesters aren't running and
screaming so he he slows down some dude
runs up into the window that's punching
oh yes this and then you see him fly
back he gets shot in the arm you know
then the dude gets out and he's got it's
guys got a gun with extension someone
said the call extendo mags I'm not a gun
person I did see this yeah and this
would story went viral and then people
were claiming CNN whitened his skin or
something I don't know if that's true
but this dude was like that when you
watch the video you can see protesters
ran up to his doors and trying to pop
them open yeah exactly what are you and
then some dudes breeches and it punches
him so he's like gun time
baby yeah yeah you just assaulted me I'm
defending myself now yep
I didn't blame him at all and this
narrative where they're like right we
extremists and so the left was saying a
crazy guy just you know tried ramming
the protesters and shot somebody and
it's like that's not true
yeah there's videos sorry again we live
in the age of the internet social media
we all see the truth we're watching
these videos now dude we're all locked
in our homes there's nothing for us to
do out there but analyze what's going on
in the world I just told you about my
friends who don't know anything right
let's train it and the knowledge gap is
insane yo driving a conversation about
race yard Brooks in Atlanta where I'm
like so did you see what happened I did
right so then it's clear-cut case of
self-defense what do you mean the guy
was sleeping you didn't know
he took a weapon pointed at the cop and
pulled the trigger and within like a
third of a second the cop responded with
three shots one two three went down in
the cop tried to trick then tried to
resuscitate him yeah well I don't know
about all that but I'm just saying like
you shouldn't die for sleeping in a
Wendy's I'm like did you not hear what I
just said let's try this again he was
driving it doesn't fit their narrative
drunk so they block it out yep it's that
emotional defense trigger right whoa oh
I need to defend my stance without kill
for my stance and then I get accused
they're like you just want to win you
don't you don't even actually trying to
have a conversation though what are you
talking about they're talking on the
mirror now yeah obviously it's true
that's true
yeah it's it's it's it's like it's
religious man yeah you're the insane
beliefs dude
seeing the the DA and Atlanta claim the
guy was kicking him when he was down
yeah that's an obvious lie and now we're
finding out he's dirty oh yeah we knew
he was dirty come on yeah come on we're
in trouble man so people are saying like
you know Trump's culture war campaign
was a bad idea
I'd record a segment on the other day
kolinsky was like it's the worst
possible strategy and I'm like I
disagree I certainly don't it's the
worst possible strategy I mean which had
a bunch of cities burned down yeah gun
sales are through the roof people are
certainly scared about George Washington
Jefferson being torn down you know what
do you think and then the response I get
is the polls are too good for Biden
Biden's gonna win and I'm like what does
that
another not a culture war is a good
strategy why you tell me about polls I'd
say Trump was gonna win yeah I said the
culture war might be a good strategy for
him yeah but they're so they're hubris
but then they get they get triggered
though it's the same thing I was talking
about I need you I need to explain to
you why my position is correct and it's
like we weren't even talking about that
it's not about their position it's about
I'm right even if I change the subject
so if I if you say if you say that
Donald Trump's campaign strategy of
embracing the culture war is a bad idea
and I said I disagree you know the the
riots have like in one anecdote a friend
of mine was like a damn anti Trump and
then after the riots another pro Trump
and then you respond with that's that's
absurd but Biden is leading in the polls
by double digits blah blah blah and I'm
like what we were talking about we
weren't talking about polls or the
election right when I'm talking about
whether cultural issues will benefit
Trump in some way not whether or not
he's gonna win because of the polls
I'm totally triggered instead of because
like they're because they need to just
counter me because I must be wrong
because they're contrarian you know
instead of like instead of addressing
what I said they change the subject
ya know but Trump will is why I didn't
say Trump was gonna win we're talking
about me what is this that's what it's
like dealing with these people
yeah so when you tell them that you know
like the NYPD you might have a reason
for actually pulling out his gun in the
video right they're like what reason
could you possibly have when that cop
pulled out his gun on those protesters
someone ran up behind his supervisor and
cracked him over there with a baton no
brick it was a brick there was a brick
so his superior officer was standing
right next to him got attacked got hit
with a brick that's that's a deadly
weapon assault attempted murder I
couldn't kill him so you're gonna be
upset because the cop pulled there and
said everyone get away he didn't shoot
they all dispersed they all ran away and
I got off the trigger yet he branded
brandished his weapon it was all I
needed to do - exactly somebody that's
all it was
now that now the cop was wearing a
helmet but that could still be a kill
shot know you're surrounded by people
bashing bricks
yes over your boss's head right so the
reason I bring this up is just because
you know you'll hear like this is insane
the cops are drawing their weapons
there's no reason for this you know why
because they cut out
of the video of course what happened
first right so all you see is a cop get
angry and draw his weapon and start
waving it around yeah that's the first
video I saw and I was like okay well
what's this about then of course the
next day they're like by the way here's
the whole story that's like oh ok so it
makes what the students know this works
and they said to realize me I know I've
been like you talk about these people
that are just blindly believe it it's
like it's not that I blindly believed it
but I was clueless when I got here is I
wasn't paying attention in the
mainstream media I mean I still kind of
don't pay attention in the mainstream
media but I'm I see what they're doing
though at least you know so I'm paying
attention to what's happening in the
world most people don't most people live
in their little bubble in their in their
little small in town or whatever city it
doesn't matter where you are everyone
everyone creates a little comfortable
life bubble for themselves and a lot of
times anything outside of that bubble
just as relevant but I'm talking about
your right I'm also talking about these
people who are activists oh yeah right
like that's the worst part of it though
they're like we must have these laws and
it's like do you know why no yeah so
look man those people are really loudest
how hard I've had conversations with
people uh you know and some of my lefty
friends saying things like there's no
reason anyone should ever have a gun and
this is years ago mind you ok like it
was only five or six months ago I said
straight up I do not want any guns in my
house I'm not I'm not hardcore anti-gun
six months ago I'm just like not for me
don't want to deal with it where we
today I just bought a ton of guns
oh okay I didn't know if you were gonna
talk about this oh yeah well I'm going
back to the progressive argument a
second but I'm just mentioning like I
went to the draft I went to the gun
store and the guy the chap was like
every time I was like I'll take that and
that he was like I'm getting jealous man
and then he said here's your
complimentary roof korean badge dude I
have Japanese you're like yep yeah I
have like World War two captured
equipment and stuff is crazy that's
pretty cool but he'd be like here's one
box of ammo but double it maybe like let
me get an expensive man there's like ten
dollars come on I'm like them it's like
I'm breaking the bank should stock up on
ammo
that's avails all them say the
apocalypse bullet sir cash money but
that's currency but anyway anyway the
reason I brought this up was not to be
like look at all my guns no no no it's
because this was back around the time we
lived in Miami and we had that situation
where the dude jumped in the yard and
all we had was the 20 to the right it
was like a remington 22 air compression
level it was a crack break barrel with
up I mean it that thing was it was
serious it would it would hurt somebody
that would it would have to be a perfect
shot to take him out to the eye but like
if you know if that I don't know who it
was because we started flashing lights
back there and they never came towards
the house but you're I don't know man
the full context yeah we lived in a kind
of like a farm in the Redlands of Miami
someone we'd heard stories about murders
somebody jumped onto our property and
was snooping around the flashlight so I
took the the 22 and I you know dry fired
in the air because it's that's a bang
yeah and then they took off yep they
were gone so you know so nothing the guy
at the gun store told me is like
typically when you want home defense a
nice pump action shotgun all you need is
that good sound and then they're gone
yeah that was actually interesting
because you know with the conversation
we're having was is a semi-auto shotgun
worth it because you don't get the pump
which scares them off right if you're
talked about home defense it might it
might not be as practical but the sound
might be more practical anyway anyways I
don't bring it up to talk about guns the
conversation was I have progressive
friends who think there's no purpose for
guns at all like have they heard of
hunting no no no like outside of that
okay they understand like oh but hunting
I guess is fine but can't you have your
guns sort of safely stored near like
where you go hunting or something or
like a special area it's nonsense
it's nonsense it's not and so that it's
like they they really do think the only
reason anyone buys a gun is because
they're laughing about how they want to
murder people like I just can't wait to
kill somebody no no no do they even like
a lot of people don't understand when at
one like after a cop shoots somebody for
any reason they have like I'm not sure
if they all do this but a lot of them go
to like psychotherapy like you just shot
somebody who died there probably cried
for like 12 hours and changing Eversley
never I'm sure it does it's a line you
can't cross you can't come back from
right exactly I'm not saying it destroys
your life but you will always you know
especially like war stuff
oh yeah to think that in any certain
look they're crazy people ma'am I'll
tell you what the people who like going
around murdering are like a fraction of
the global population and they're insane
yeah it was it actually has a funny
thought consider we're talking about war
I remember someone I was talking to
someone a long time ago lefty about
getting rid of the prison system okay
and when I was like yeah but like what
do you do with murderers
they're like sent him to Middle East you
serious yeah put him in the army they
want to kill people and I'm like not so
do you have they have crazy laws about
the rules of engagement and like but
maybe that's the place where they need
to be worth Oh flourish a lot of times
these murderers they're picking people
that are weak they're they're they're
not it's a it's a power it's a trip
thing that they they deal with - it's
not like this is true don't want to
fight against someone that's equal that
has a gun that's fighting them no they
want to go murder people that don't kill
civilians yeah exactly it's like you
know you know it's crazy the argument I
was yeah I know I was like look you
can't get rid of prisons man and I'm
like I'm all for prison reform I don't
like private prisons I agree with that
yeah like there are good arguments for
private prisons but they tend to just in
my opinion go in direction that's bad
where you know create a pipeline like
there are judges who have sold kids to
these private juvenile centers taking
kickbacks yeah so there's also problems
with government prisons
yeah we gotta get rid of reform a lot
there's a lot in our government that
needs to be reformed one hundred percent
agreed and but they're talking about
sins absolutely they want to destroy
everything they want to burn it all down
yeah see from the ashes of the old
ability it's like it we have food in our
fridges and at our stores here you want
to burn a society down you're not gonna
eat anymore
let's talk about it let's talk about
privilege yeah you wanna talk about I
just ordered a vegan bacon cheeseburger
how good with sweet potato fries was
that it was good I know I had a
yesterday so there's there's a
restaurant near us that has like a full
vegan menu and amazing oh yeah so I
found this place just just had to say
that no no seriously this this place is
amazing it's a diner
I love diners diner foods the best going
to have a diner
and this I found this place is really
nearby the head chef is vegan no qualms
about cooking anything for anyone else
cool but made a huge vegan menu makes
all this like vegan meat by himself
there and it is incredible it's really
really good so good but this is like to
see these people in the Chaz yep that
are so insanely clueless you want to
talk about privilege yeah you know what
I'll tell you this I respect the sjw's
when they complain about privilege what
I don't respect is that the umbrella of
their of their perspective of privilege
goes too far
so when they come out and talk about
white privilege if they just held up a
mirror I'd be like you are correct
indeed that you are talking about
yourself yeah who is the privilege of
not reading news not learning from
history going to an autonomous zone and
then asking for vegan food it's like
listen I'll tell you what that had me
cracking up I gotta be honest if you
want a privilege Oh yet you are
privileged weakened we could have
donations but we want a vegan food like
we want you to go to the specialty aisle
at the at the local Whole Foods to get
the good stuff like now if you if you
want to go autonomous and you don't want
to live in society you got to go shoot
your own animals eat cockroaches meet
bugs you you can't handle it
there isn't you shouldn't be autonomous
then this is the other privilege now
look a lot of them are vegan all right
sure I can respect that okay then great
look the algae I don't know I don't know
what I don't know I don't know what
vegan food you're gonna be growing yeah
what city made a concrete with 200 other
people in a small little segregated
garden so you're only gonna get from the
what is race you are garden I guess this
is the privilege of this country and and
so I am trying to tie this into like we
were just talking about yeah these
people who think you never need a gun
right the people who think that
everything is hand is hand holding
skittles and rainbows and caviar living
in their comfortable little bubble that
society has built that we have all been
living in comfortable being able to poop
in the toilet let that poop get flushed
away where do where's it go do you even
have any idea what happens to the poop
yeah probably not that is peak privilege
right there no it's not about the fact
that your poop gets carried away it's
that you don't even think about it you
don't did you think about it you see
that family is it family episode where
they were inter-dimensionally tree
No so Stewie and Brussels bruh Stewie
shows up to like a farm festival or
something and it has the winning Pig
okay but the pig has fists and it's
super ripped and he goes oink oink his
name is Jeff and then he punches Brian
and Brian's like where did this thing
come from and studi says he went to
another dimension they' so he show he's
showing Brian around and they go to this
futuristic dimension where apparently
the the Dark Age had never happened so
it's like very futuristic okay and
Brian's like I got it I got out of the
bathroom what do I do and Stewie says
one poop removal and then Brian stops
and goes wow it has gone like yes out of
his body it's like wow what a future
yeah but hold on what a future think
about it every all of these people have
grown up in a society where everything
was given to them and they don't even
have to consider where their poop goes
that's true I know it's funny to mention
poop do you think it's silly sexy shells
did the see you just rub the first one
think about one or two then you go
either the one or the two and that makes
it go away the toilet thing is funny
right yeah yeah but but it's true hello
I wasn't great break trying to be funny
I know I know but break this down check
it out if you live in the middle of
nowhere that this is why I think the
rural areas tend to be very conservative
you might have to actually dig an
outhouse or work on a septic tank yeah
it's good to understand like so if you
have a septic tank for the most part
they're very low maintenance right but
you got to remind people like hey you
can't flush whatever you want good you
live in the city what do they do they
flip their cigarettes in it flush
whatever whatever the paper towel no
food yep you know the just whatever just
like got rid of it
and they have no idea where it goes none
yep they don't think about it I think I
think that privilege is not having to
think about it
like someone who doesn't have to think
about ever ever using a gun that is peak
privilege to live in a country where you
don't ever have to think what if any
yourself who is that guy I keep
forgetting his name where he said you
know saying you can just call the police
is asking the maid to take it out well
it's a tower so ivory you can't look at
it and direct sunlight it was Caleb
something killed oh it's uh it's the
it's the gun it's the Second Amendment
equivalent of saying just
the maid do it for real it's true yeah
especially if you live in my room
but but think about it from the
perspective of human black lives matter
where they say they're scared to call
cops you know that's another good good
point if you if you don't think you can
rely on the police to protect you
because of problems in your community
and corruption well then you need to be
able to defend yourself yep yes this is
actually really interesting to could I
did an interview with a woman in Chicago
who was Pro to a think I wanted gun
accountability yes she said the problem
was that a lot of these young guys are
getting illegal guns that can't be
traced can't be tracked and then they're
selling them and trading them off and
that's where the kids think they can get
away with this stuff and she was like
she's like I'm armed like I got my legal
gun and it's legal and we need to figure
out how we can get you know the people
in this you know in the city to legally
protect themselves and stop the flow of
the illegal guns that can't be traced
and that was interesting because this is
a woman in the black community was a
black woman arguing in favor and Second
Amendment and against Chicago gun
violence and her solution was actually
an armed in polite society which I found
interesting because I was like I gotta I
gotta admit I'm not sure if that's you
know so that you said that last week
it's like if more people are if
everyone's armed it's like well that's
um I don't know I we were not saying it
like you said it per se but you're
talking about it and you're like well
well so the fence sitting equivalent
however you say that basically was uh I
like I'm not convinced that these kids
will stop killing each other over stupid
things just because the guns are legal
right and she humbly disagreed as
someone who lived there saying that one
of the reasons they feel so brazen is
that they get them on the fly on the
spot super easy and they think they
can't be tracked so they're like now I
can get away with him then you get rid
of it you know and if it was if the if
we got rid of that flow because one of
the problems as I was explained to me is
that Indiana has more lacks than Chicago
that Chicago and Chicago and Indiana
like Chicago actually the metro area
overlaps into Indiana right so people
drive in by Tony easy guns bring him
right back and these kids take him
illegally it's not like there's borders
or anything so I'm not I'm not in how he
can miss an argument right but I thought
it was interesting that the solution she
proposed as someone who actually lived
there was more like legal guns for
people to protect themselves so we can
defend you know depend on ourselves but
yeah man yo Kaiser
tez was asked about police reform and
she was asked what she thinks it would
look like he said the suburbs it's like
you're literally saying have the maid do
it you're literally saying we should
have the nice well-funded tonight that
was her answer
yeah the suburbs what would your police
reform look like the suburbs
she said that's not an answer no she's
saying have they made do it that's the
most cop-out answer I've ever heard and
I'll tell you what if you live in if you
live in Chicago the scary thing is you
probably need a gun there more than most
of their places I believe it I believe
it Chicago I mean 100 people got shot
over the weekend 104 104 people got shot
not killed but shot and 14 died 14 died
the week before I think it was like 26
died it's insane so you might want to be
able to defend your home yeah from
violence maybe have the cops right
what's the saying when when seconds
matter the police are minutes away yep
yeah and everyone's like well why aren't
they why aren't they there before the
situation happens it's like because they
can't what pre-crime pre-crime my
already reporting exist sorry okay okay
hold on I got it all we got to do is
find some precogs
great build the facility and then we can
arrest people who haven't yet committed
crimes because they world yes pre-crime
and then we could create a matrix system
for all the pre criminals yeah and throw
them in there I think that was the only
problem like if you could intervene and
stop the crime from happening it won't
happen right you know exactly though it
was a good hike that movie time Chris is
good yeah yes
anyway we got into the gun stuff but so
so look man it was this is a true story
like five or six months ago I
straight-up was having a conversation
and I said I do not want any guns in my
house yep and we had we had nothing no
nothing and then cope it happened and
then I was lying you were preparing for
a possible apocalypse and then the riots
started when yeah
so when kovat happened and I saw people
were going nuts to buy guns I started
researching like what I had to do
actually I uh it's a it's actually
earlier than this it was a September
when someone tried breaking in I
immediately was like okay I should go
figure out what I need to do know what
the police officer said to you yeah
yeah he said if it were me I answer the
door the shotgun yeah and then you like
and I'm like I hear what you say yep
August what yeah it's probably obvious
you get it I'll tell you what though
it's good advice but then you know what
I think I got lulled into a false sense
of security things calm down I was like
I think we're okay we're fine and that
is privileged right there it is easier
if people forget how comfortable we are
as Americans our poop just goes right
away yeah I don't even think twice we
could drive to the store and buy
practically anything where does it go
somebody money we want free combust yeah
yeah dude well that was the point about
the vegan food right right I was like so
we're gonna get dinner and I was like if
I can why not you know I've tried some
of that stuff before is pretty good I
think I think I'll try like wow the
burger it was great so good well made I
don't know I don't even earrings my
goodness I don't I don't even because it
is I typically just do chicken and fish
for the most part yeah and so I like
beef makes me sick it always has for the
most part I do love beef tartare but I
just so I'm like I'll get the burger you
know and and with the vegan bacon or
whatever and I can just snap my fingers
and in 20 minutes there was this like
it's a it's a it's a privilege beyond
recognition to be able to have something
so specific you know to cater to your
your needs you know whereas in a lot of
parts of the world there's eat crickets
that's real it's like wow I think what I
can get whatever they have to rock up
and there's ropes you know whatever
does boots food man they actually forage
still this is the big problem I think we
have with this generation the Chad's
people right yeah but she has people is
what happens when you like it's like man
it's like a privilege pimple and you pop
it and they're the gunk that sprays out
it's a disgusting image it's posted me I
was trying to think of something really
gross that worked
nailed it so it's just like it's you
know it's like infection and pus and
like it's it's these people who so your
analogy is the immune system right
it's each acting them yeah so pus is
just a collection of blood cells yeah I
think we should talk about surrounding
its surrounding the infection yeah it's
trying to attack bring it and push it
out of the body it's you imagine if a
cop slowly started moving the Chas one
block every day
I got to the water and just shove them
all in they put them onto little rafts
and they kick the wraps off then the
rats just drift away go be autonomous
somewhere else and then like three
months later they're in like Alaska and
they're just like shivering on these
like wooden pallets just floating in the
ocean oh they'll create an island or
they can go to plastic island and just
like Yap it all together and make a new
new country out there so there's a bunch
of factors in chess okay that prove the
privilege one I think the vegan tweet
may have been faked
but yeah well no no that wasn't from
chess that was from Portland oh that was
yeah yeah
that woman was in chess no she wasn't no
it was from the Portland branch of an
autonomous attempting it wasn't it
didn't go full-blown like Chaz Dean yeah
but it was kind of when it was all
happening and that was them in Portland
so it's kind of it's funny how it got
wrapped into the whole Chaz thing
because it's not the same privilege is
showing up to someone else's home
surrounding with guns and thinking you
own the place and what's really funny is
you want to talk about white privilege
and colonizers and all that stuff like
okay yeah that's what you're doing
European European colonists came to this
country started taking stuff and guess
what we frown upon the bad things they
did yeah we don't look back on
Christopher Columbus in the story about
the Native Americans and the slave girls
ago that's the best part of Christopher
Columbus we know that was the worst part
yeah I've been condemning Christopher
Columbus day for a long time and it's
now indigenous people today and I love
it like yeah I don't look I think you
have bad people you have winners and
losers right and you look at someone
like Columbus and and the things that
he's accused of doing and here's the big
challenge how much of what we know is
based on fact or based on a revision of
history by activists we're trying to
justify their extremism right this is
what this is what the really scary thing
to me is what I was told about
Christopher Columbus is marginally
different from what the activists claim
about him okay and it's because my
schools did mention you know the
enslavement he would bring back some of
the indigenous and stuff but the way the
leftist describes it is that he's like
literally Hitler now I wonder are they
saying that because they need propaganda
to justify the array the erasing of our
culture and our history did you know for
the Revolution and all stuff think about
that think and think about everything
else they've claimed and how much of you
know you can even you can think about
the most extreme things they've said
like you know Jefferson as an evil slave
owner yeah then you actually look at
Jefferson's history and while he was a
product of the time he actually did
advocate for ending slavery although he
still had slaves for sure he was not a
perfect person you know a lot of people
no one was back then but he was he was
typically a good guy who believed in
freedom and created the framework for a
great country that has freedom that
freed everybody for the most part yeah
it's like you're erasing the history
that led us here but think about the
lies they've said right the things are
trying to make up they leave the lenin
statue statue up in seattle and tear
down everything else that makes me go
far back and think how much how much of
everything else was a lie were these
were these people they claim we're
really bad really really that bad I
don't know yeah they made that that's
one of the things I think they're doing
is trying to muddy and fog history with
with with you know over at propaganda
and stuff like that
it makes it it makes it difficult to to
know what's real and I think that's part
of the plan
if no one can tell what's real then you
haven't you have a chance to come in and
manipulate them as what they're doing
Hank's going back to what started this
conversation the people I know who have
no idea what happen with Rashad Brooks
who think he was just sleeping in his
car mining his own business they walk
him said haha
bang-bang not realizing that he got out
gave a guy concussion fought him off
stole the Taser fired at him and then
got shot in self-defense so how do you
deal with these people and how do you
change the stuff man talk about
privilege but I do I do want to go back
real quick - the poop analogy yes oh
please but it's it actually tonight it's
so here's here's the analogy I've used
in the past these people in New York for
instance these progressives okay they
woke up one day in their life and there
was a giant bridge the Manhattan Bridge
yep the Williamsburg Bridge the Brooklyn
Bridge the Queensboro Bridge man what
else is there the Washington Washington
Bridge can they walk across it yep yep
all these bridges just there and I'm
thinking about like what was life like
back in the 1800s when you were in New
York and you're like my friend lives in
Brooklyn I see him maybe once every
other month because you've got to
literally get in a boat and cross I'm
sure there were ferry services yeah
but it wasn't something so you like nice
walk so these people grow up and all of
the hard work and labor of the pioneers
who created this this privileged world
yeah is forgotten on them they think
they're standing on solid ground and
they're standing on the shoulders of
thousands of giants they don't realize
how much energy labor work went into
making all of those bridges that allow
them to just walk right over to
Williamsburg and get there or skate or
skate and get that light nice little you
know almond milk vegan frappe you know
little foam and stevia extract yeah all
the really fancy total privilege yeah
but that's that's the toilet thing too
it's like you knew you when you live in
the middle of nowhere when you go
camping they tell you what you have to
do to deal with your waste have any of
these people ever thought about what
that means
definitely not or where their food comes
from out of the mouth they don't that's
why when they try a for comes from the
storm
Tim yeah I know it comes from the store
I don't buy it you you're not joking you
think you're Joe no no I'm joking Glee
serious yes you know they've actually
said that yeah I know
protesters have literally said we'll
just get food from the store I'm not I'm
not talking I'm not I'm not wait I'm
sorry I did not know that they actually
have said that they're I can't member
exactly when this was but there was a
viral tweet where someone was asking
like come on if you you know if you shut
down like the roads and the farms where
people get their food the response was
like we'll get it from the store like
where do you think the store gets the
food from what do you mean what do you
mean where does he stocked every week
where does the food come from the food
from the stores and you're like no no no
the store sells the food right gets it
from somewhere else oh I don't know they
don't make it I'm not exaggerating they
think all the food in the stores this is
probably the one this is probably one
dump okay well that one person is crazy
with yang supporters we're talking about
milk like where does the milk come from
you just you miss everything you cut
everything out of the middle and you
still get milk they're like we're still
getting milk you still have no no that's
right was give the what were they saying
we were talking about like when the
economy shut down I said what you don't
understand is that it's like imagine of
this big train and then all of a sudden
the front just stops okay all those
train carts
can't just stop either so they all start
crashing into each other piling up and
flipping off the tracks and you know you
know crashing everywhere and so I made a
point about how if the farms can't
produce milk the stores don't have milk
so and they were like dude you're so
dumb oh my god they can just send the
milk back to the stores okay what they
didn't understand they think they
thought that like there's a cow and the
farmer walks up it goes opera dart with
a count with a fresh empty gallon it's
got you know farmers milk on it
fix it of the cow and go squirt squirt
squirt caps it and then walks to the
store most there's one gallon of milk to
saltier your customers like no the dairy
farm they have they have six bleach out
all the pus oh god dude yeah it's a true
rose have you have you ever seen milk
from organic good farm stuff is the only
stuff I would drink although it's still
no that stuff that stuff's way better I
know because I visited the farms that
produce that still grow there's a lot of
really really bad farms but the organic
stuff I've been to those farms and I've
interviewed I've watched the cows it's a
lot it's a lot better but anyway the
point is the dairy farms have big metal
tanks of milk mm-hmm it's unprocessed
raw they send it for processing and
packaging to a different company yep who
then sends it to warehouse distributors
who ship it off in trucks to stores you
know if you break the economy then the
dairy farmer has no plastic
you know processing plant send it to
yeah because they the economy has just
shut down and not only that
that's one product yep we've just talked
about one hog in the wheel of society
that puts food in the store to your
plate they these people have no idea
they don't understand they are pink they
are playing a video game because in
video games everything magically appears
in your backpack everything you eat some
food you go buy more food at the with a
NPC dealer whatever it's like think
about think about fallout have no idea
you can carry 300 pounds but 301 and
then you slow down and then then your
number then your then your encumbered so
so these people are like they live in
this fantasy world yeah
like the video from Chaz where the
medics trying to get in or the medical
refuse to come in is the
perfect example true you're like we
don't want any police in here and then
the medics are like we're not coming in
or the video letting this guy bleed out
you see that you see the video where the
they throw garbage at a guy's car and
then he jumps at with the blades on his
wrist I saw that he's got like four
blades like a weird car have any made
that himself and they yell call the cops
Oh police police and he's like he's like
he's gonna get you these listen man
all of these videos where like the guy
drives up into the protoss and they
shoot somebody they go call the cops man
call the cops it's like bro the cops are
there yeah protesting them abolish them
completely what these people are plumb
nuts not crazy I'm crazy okay I wonder
where these these phrases come from nuts
we should get an analogous to talk about
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you